GoodGood
[Music] I
named it Hiroko's mille-feuille duxelle and
ate it
.
The shiitake mushrooms are slowly flooded with ice and the umami of the mushrooms is locked in,
slowly enhancing the earthy flavor
.
And in terms of the best taste, Sanmin
Ono-san, actually,
what kind of ingredients have sourness?
Indeed, it is beneficial to consume a large amount of Mr. Tree, but if it is a small amount, it
will be a wonderful accent.
It's possible to express the taste.It's
completely reached the top
level.Gaya Arita's appearance is too much and the taste becomes better, so the spear is the pole.It's amazing.
If you use the ingredients perfectly, it's a delicate and elegant
appetizer menu.
[music]